let's go next to our caller from the  five-one-six-- area code who is calling  today from five one six hello this is  Devan so I used to have one question yes  yes do you think that opening an  investigation into Meccano and other  likely or obviously complicit Senate  Republicans might give us a chance that  conviction in the Senate you know put  them on hot coals you know no probably  not they'd stone wallet they'd play the  martyr victim game and Fox News would  help him do it so now I unfortunately  even if it would be the right thing to  do to investigate them I don't believe  that we would really get much out of it  unfortunately it's it's I hate to be  this cynical but it's the way I see it  hmm because I was thinking about you  know how we're possibly going to be  investigating newness in the house but  right alright thank you all right thank  you very much appreciate the phone call